[Music]
he
a let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not not
Liberty you [__] eating [__] ah the
smell of freedom of speech this is the
Tony Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them has Christmas come early this
year
or will the Supreme Court
stick coal in our
stockings which is it what do you
think oh the debate is on and the Civil
War is taking place
online and Trump derangement syndrome is
[__] real holy [__] it is real and
I'm not just talking about the left I'm
talking about the right too ho holy
[__] absolutely [__]
ridiculous now I told you months and
months and months ago that this 14th
Amendment [__] is ridiculous and it
still
is I told you it go to Supreme Court and
it's going to no matter no matter what
the decision was at the Colorado Supreme
Court this was going to go to the
Supreme Court it was G to go
the group was going to appeal it Trump
was going to appeal it it didn't matter
and I told you that you do not want you
do not
want the Supreme Court to answer this
question now a lot of people are [__]
losing their minds that Trump's off the
ballot this is not the general election
ballot which is a big
issue it's a primary ballot in Colorado
and the question is can Colorado take
Trump off the primary the Republican
primary
ballot for Insurrection which he has not
been charged with Insurrection he should
be but he has not been and he has not
been convicted of insurrection that is
part of the issue here now I know you're
going to say section three in amendment
14 is very clear and it's
clearcut no it's not that is why we are
doing this how don't you [__] know
this it's not clear-cut if it was
clear-cut and dry we would already have
this question answered the problem I
have with the question is we don't need
to answer this question we definitely do
not want this Supreme Court answering
this question I have a feeling a lot of
people are going to be
disappointed Left Right Center
but it's the PE people who have the
Trump derangement syndrome that are
really making this a wild ride of a
nothing
Burger even if okay there's two options
here really well there's three there's
three options the Supreme Court could
just say not we're going to punt this
[__] we don't want to make this decision
[__] that [__] which is not probably
what they're going to do and he would
stay off the primary ballot in Colorado
folks
remember this it is the Republicans who
brought this case to keep him off the
primary ballot not the general election
ballot now I understand that it could
snowball and the legality of this could
snowball to the general election ballot
but the argument is is oh man this is
really going to snowball into other
states folks listen the Iowa caucus is
January
15th almost every single one of these
cases and almost all these other states
have dropped their
cases because there's not time to keep
him off a primary
ballot okay even if you keep him off a
primary ballot in Colorado let's say one
two two other maybe three other states
keep him on primary ballots you think
he's not going to have enough delegates
to win the nomination at the convention
then we have to do the same court battle
for the general election
ballot you're not you're I I mean
clearly clearly Trump derangement
syndrome is real and what I mean by this
is on the left and the right they're
[__] deranged with him focused on him
not our
democracy okay that's the problem that
I've had with this the entire time I've
been trying to tell you I've been trying
to [__] point it out to
you who gives a [__] about him why are
we spending so much time and
energy to single out him we will beat
him we can beat him and we will beat him
we the [__]
people okay we do not need the Supreme
Court answering this stupid [__]
question
now the mate teers are the best part
about
this I look I mean the thing that I like
about this decision the most really
honestly oh my God just oceans of mate
teers and you guys know how I love
swimming in mate tiers I mean it's the
best kind of [__] swim you could
take and and of course they have Trump
derangement syndrome because they're
bringing up all kinds of crazy ass weird
[__] the weirdest part about it and the
best tears of all these people crowd
around and they yell and scream this
ain't a democracy it's a
republic and then last night as soon as
this decision hits as soon as it drops
they're like oh so we don't have a
democracy anymore I'm like oh yeah it's
real Rich coming from you it's this is a
republic
crowd it's not a democracy Tony it's a
republic oh so we don't have have a
democracy anymore do you see what Trump
derangement syndrome does oh my God it
makes you I don't know [__] wildly
out of step with reality like just you
can't even you like pick what you
believe and then [__] believe it okay
pick what you believe pick a
position
and keep your position it's really
[__] wild stuff the left the same way
it's the same way I saw a bunch of
people that I normally respect their
opinion last night saying [__] like well
if the Supreme Court decides that Trump
can get away with this and get on the
ballot then then Joe Biden can be
president forever that's the dumbest
[__] I've ever heard of in my life These
are stupid [__] arguments listen
there is a really good chance a really
good chance that the Supreme Court is
going to side with Trump on this there's
a couple reasons why that is horrible
okay one reason why it's horrible is
because this will be the first case that
he wins this will be the first case he
wins since January 6 in the Supreme
Court is that what you want right before
the primaries you want him to start
having a winning record in the Supreme
Court you people are wild it's crazy
stuff he's likely to win now if he loses
if he loses and they keep him off that
ballot now it creates whole other world
of legal problemss and now we're going
to have to chase around these stupid
shiny objects because each state has
different laws and each state is going
to have to bring their own case before
The Supreme
Court and every one of them will be
different because they will have
different
merits this is why I told you this this
14th Amendment
stuff is just not the road that you want
to go down
so much time so much energy and he's
still going to be the
nominee because Trump derangement
syndrome is weird stuff the left last
night on Twitter seemed to think that he
won't be on any ballots anywhere and
that's just not the [__]
truth it's not how this is going to
work it's not how the law
Works they have to all bring their
[__] case
the flimsiest part about this and if you
go read the 14th Amendment section
three you clearcut and dry [__]
that's
right talking to
you if you go read
it it clearly spells out it clearly
spells
out
Insurrection now we all know he
committed Insurrection we all know that
we know know that we saw it with our own
eyes that that doesn't matter to
courts that doesn't that doesn't matter
I don't know if you know that that they
don't take your
feeling about it into account it's not
what they do it's not what courts should
do Court shouldn't be
[__] letting Pitchfork mobs decide
the fate of someone that's not Justice
okay it's not I don't care who the [__]
it is and you can't single out
him look the future of of our democracy
is Wily more important than
Trump okay wildly more important than
Trump the future of our democracy is so
much more important than Trump will ever
be or ever dream of
being it's so [__] important
and these questions that we are trying
to ask the court to to to save us
because that's really how some people
feel about it that they're going to save
us that Colorado this Colorado state
supreme court saved us it was a 43
decision it was a 4-3 decision and not
only was it a 4-3 decision in their
decision they were like yeah we're going
to let the Supreme Court of the United
States decide this that's what they did
cuz they stay it immediately like
they're like hey we're going to take him
off the ballot but we're not actually
going to take him off the
ballot it's what they did go go read the
[__] go read
it go read
it I I know 4-3 is a win I get it but
again it's a 4-3 decision to let the
Supreme Supreme Court decide is what it
was that that's how it [__]
reads that's what they decided the
Supreme Court of Colorado decided to let
the Supreme Court of the United States
decide this issue now they set it up in
a way to where the Supreme Court could
definitely decide to keep Trump off the
ballot I will agree with that they made
the case inside the ford3 decision to
make it easy for this Supreme Court to
keep him off the Colorado primary ballot
but that is what you're talking about
specifically in this
decision that because of insurrection
the Insurrection
Clause that they could keep Trump off
the primary ballot that was missed a lot
last night too everyone thought no one
no one is or he can't be on the general
election ballot in Colorado that's a
completely different
decision I mean if the decision goes
correctly to keep him off the ballot
then it might keep him off the general
election ballot that might be an easy
one why are we wasting this
energy why when we should be wasting
energy on creating a narrative in this
country where this guy standing on stage
talking about mind comp
folks I don't know if you watched this
last night but in the same night where
the Supreme Court of Colorado decided
that they would keep him off the ballot
and let the Supreme Court decide if they
would put him back on the ballot because
that what decision was he's standing on
stage in waterl Iowa
waterl waterl Iowa talking
about Mike gum he's saying the words out
out
loud saying the [__] words out
loud this ain't going to be hard
folks they're going to nominate him I
don't know I don't know if you noticed
ve radama dingdong that was like oh well
we're gonna stand in solidarity and no
one's GNA be on the ballot not Ronda
STIs not Nikki Haley I'm calling on
Chris Christie to not be on the ballot
in
Colorado so your answer to if Donald
Trump doesn't can't win then no one can
win this is really dumb this is really
stupid and it's it's bound to be an
interesting year well yeah it's gonna be
a year maybe a little over a year
because when he loses to Joe Biden he's
definitely going to deny that he lost
he's going to spend the big line again
all the folks on the right that have
Trump derangement
syndrome are going to be out and about
helping and sell his
lie but Trump derangement syndrome is
real and it's it it's it's
on it's on both sides really is I mean I
hate to admit it because everyone's like
Tony you got Trump derangement syndrome
and there some righties um because I
pointed out this morning that the it's a
republic crowd was talking about how
they're losing democracy over this
decision which is really [__] rich
and they were all up in my comments oh
it's all you lefties and blah blah blah
I'm like what the [__] man you haven't
come and watch my show I am not for this
14th Amendment [__] I am not I think
it's a bad [__] I think it's a bad
move it's a really bad move for our
democracy for the future to [__] try
to do this thing to him when we can
[__] beat
him it's so easy to [__] beat
him and they're trying to convince you
that you can't with these stupid [__]
rigged up
polls it's really dumb but do you know
who doesn't have Trump derangement
syndrome do you know who doesn't have
it just normal average people who aren't
paying attention they're not paying
attention most people woke up this
morning and don't even know what that
[__] [__] in Colorado means won't
even hear about
it they won't even hear about it until
the Supreme Court makes the decision
okay most people are not [__] wildly
crazy about Trump they [__] hate his
guts they don't want him to be president
most people are like [__] no I'm not
voting for that some [__] but they
don't have Biden derangement syndrome
either okay most of the people who are
going to vote in the next election they
don't have Trump derangement syndrome
and they don't have Biden derangement
syndrome
okay neither of those things the
majority of Voters that will cast
ballots have neither one of those
things and they will make their their
decision objectively based on narratives
they
will they will look at the narratives
they will be objective to their own
beliefs and their own principles and
they will make that decision regardless
regardless of what this decision is or
what comes from this decision which
honestly I don't even see how this
decision keeps him off other state
ballots because there's not enough
time those state courts would have to
take up those cases and work their way
to the Supreme Court there's a process
and a lot of those state state cases for
the 14th Amendment have already dropped
half of them I think or more than
half and it is it is Trump derangement
syndrome when
you're you're cheering on the
courts to subvert a certain part of our
Dem democracy because you don't like
Trump and you don't like that Jack Smith
didn't charge him with Insurrection and
you don't like that it didn't happen
quick enough to convict him of
insurrection it's a feeling that you
have a problem with it's a feeling it's
not the law it's not the law it's not I
mean you you you people clearly
understand how I feel about Trump and
Maga you clearly understand
it but I believe our democracy is much
more important than they
are way more important way more
significant than Trump or Manga will
ever dream of [__]
being that's why I fight for it it's why
I on screen that's why I defend my
positions for it I don't I don't [__]
go on the internet and go oh this is the
popular opinion so I'll go on my show
and I'll say this because it's the
popular opinion I don't read my chat the
whole way through to see how you guys
are responding to my commentary and
change my commentary based on how you're
say you're responding to it it's not
what I
do it's not what I ever will
do you can count on
it that's why more and more people are
going to come listen to what the [__]
I'm
saying and they're going to crowd in
here
rather they [__] like what I'm saying
they hate what I'm saying or they just
agree with me 60% of the time 70% of the
time 90% of the time they're going to
come and the reason why is because most
people don't have these derangement
syndromes they're not constantly [__]
looking for something to be [__]
outraged or offended by they
don't they're not constantly trying to
figure out which
party is the best
party they got Common Sense ideas they
got Common Sense principles most those
people vote with those principles in
this country based on what narrative is
being spoken at the
time it's how it's How elections work
it's how they work for a long
time and the media's lost its power over
the last 20 years to absolutely control
the narrative they've lost it
they've lost control of it and the
internet and technology is one big
reason for it is one big reason for
it and I told you yesterday about the
narrative that we have to have with row
rage because there is there's two
important [__] narratives that we
must focus on for 2024 two two [__]
narratives
two two of
them
they want to
take women's [__] rights away they
want to criminalize Women's Health Care
and they want to ban their
privacy and they're going to come for
you next they're starting there and
they're going to come for you
next the next narrative is that Donald
Trump wants to be a dictator Grant Paul
Hitler is reading mind comp well I don't
actually think he's reading that would
reading mine that would assume that he
actually can read I think Steven Miller
is probably reading minec conf to him
you know what I mean like he's reading
it to
him they're having like a a Maga mind
conf book club down at Mar
Lago if you w to speak the
language those are the two
narratives that's it folks those two
narratives those two things if we drive
those home and keep pressing those and
pressing those and pressing those and
pressing those we will
win this fight to try to keep him off
the ballot which I don't think it's
going to
work you have high hopes you have high
hopes for this supreme court and I know
people are like yeah but Tony Neil
Gorsuch Neil Gorsuch decide and they
even put that case in this decision Tony
I'm like look if you think that Neil
Gores is grounded in principle and he's
not going to make a hypocritical
decision at the Supreme Court you're out
of your [__]
mind you're out of your mind all this
all this all of it all of it is to say
see a court did say that he committed
Insurrection when we all already know it
we know he did
he's [__] telling us he
did why why do [__] liberals have
this intellectual need to have some sort
of evidence and proof of something well
he did because this court has decided he
committed Insurrection they always got
to have a poll they always got to have a
piece of data they always got to be
[__] smarter than
you it pisses the rest of the country
off it really does it pisses the rest of
the country off it pisses them
off average working everyday people who
really don't pay attention to politics
that much it really does [__] piss
them off when when you think you're
smarter than they are it
does now we are smarter than
manga because they're delusional it's
not because their intelligence is
lacking because they got brain
worms all right and it's okay to point
that out that's okay but this whole
thing where you need to [__] press
polls and data and you got to have some
sort of [__] you got to have some
sort of [__] evidence to prove your
point because you're smarter than this
person or that person is really [__]
it's draining and it's
exhausting people people get sick of it
they
do and it doesn't help you like it
doesn't help your cause it doesn't help
your narrative it
doesn't it
doesn't and I know because because
you're following it every day and you're
watching it and you're getting pissed
and you're like oh my God this is crazy
look what's
happening cuz you're paying attention to
it they're not they're not paying
attention to it it's the
reality now I know I know you're like
well that's the problem with our
countries people don't pay attention
enough well I get it right we have to
get them to pay attention that's what
the yelling and the screaming that's
what the narrative is about that's what
the messaging is about that's why we
have to have shows like
this that's how the right has done
it that's how the right has done
it and they'll continue to do it and
they're going to do it with
lies not with the
truth so it's up to you it's up to you
it's up to you it really is up to you
you can be objective and you can look
further than your [__]
nose on what this decision
means CA we don't know what this
decision
means no matter how they decide this
whether they're for Trump in this which
they're definitely going to allow him to
be on the state ballot because I have a
feeling that this Supreme Court is gonna
say oh remember how we're for States
right yeah we're not for that anymore
and uh States definitely shouldn't be
telling the federal government how to
run Federal elections that's what
they're gonna
say that's what they're I mean you're
giving them way too much credit if you
think this court Pack full a bunch of
[__]
is is gonna is going to make a
decision other than the decision that
they want to
make it's wild stuff and I saw [__] last
night people like oh well the Court's in
on it the court wants to get rid of him
and I'm like what the [__] are you
talking
about what are what are you talking
about they have like like there's
there's a q andon brainworm that Haron
Hitler has paid a [__] ton of money for
in pacting that Supreme
Court okay a [__] ton of
it it's wild
stuff but look we're gonna get through
this we're going to get through this
decision no matter what the decision is
he will still be the nominee they are
not going to not nominate him I mean all
the all the Republican
[__] all all the other Republicans in
the primary like oh this's is a bunch of
[__] you can't keep him off the
ballot like it helps them and they're
saying the
[Laughter]
opposite I don't I you're not paying
attention if you don't if you don't see
it if you don't see it and it's okay
it's okay if we disagree it's okay if
you don't want me to say the things that
I'm saying it's okay it'll be okay we're
still going to be in this we're still
going to be in Coalition we're still
going to win de we're going to save
democracy because we are going to win
the 2024 election up and down the ticket
and the reason why is because we are
going to work together to make the
narrative row rage and Grandpa Hitler
loves mine comp and I'm gonna show you
why he loves mine comp and he definitely
knows what mine comp said don't go
anywhere I'm going to show you I'm going
to show you that I'm going to show you
that clip right after to this we'll be
right
back we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
podcast are you ready for best pizza of
Life bring friends down to pepperoni hug
spot our chefs make pizza with heart and
Special Touch cheese pepperoni vegetable
and more secret things
need delivery pizzas come fast knock
knock who's there pizza magic eat
pepperoni hug spot Pizza your tummy say
thank you your mouth say m pepperoni hug
spot it's like family but with more
cheese catch Tony's twitch stream the
[__] list Roundup at
twitch.tv/ thony Michaels we're back to
the king of Brilliance this is the T T
Michaels
[Music]
podcast it's like family but with more
cheese that's that's like a perfect
description uh of our chat isn't
it it's like the perfect description of
it it's like
family but with a shitload more cheese
Merry [__] Christmas to you I got a
couple pieces of business I want to talk
about but before we move on before I
show you a few of these clips of grantpa
talking about how he loves m gum CU
that's what he's saying I
mean I'll show it to
you so so a couple pieces of business
this will be our last show uh before
Christmas holiday so we'll be off
tomorrow and Friday and Monday and
Tuesday next week so we will be back
next Wednesday next Wednesday we'll be
back at our regular time regular place
as long as they don't ban me for today's
show and in the
meantime Facebook YouTube twitch and now
Instagram there seems to be a bunch of
people watching on Instagram I didn't
know if people would but apparently they
are now if you're on Instagram and
you're listening and you're typing in
comments I I can't see them I I can't
see
them because the comments doesn't come
in too my broadcast my my my my virtual
broadcast studio so I can't see them so
if you are rage commenting on Instagram
thank you for engaging over there keep
doing that but if you want me to see
them you're probably going to go to want
to go to Facebook YouTube or twitch and
I and I want to say thank you to
everyone through um our ban and our
suspension on YouTube and Facebook for
joining us on Twitch it meant so much we
grew the twitch channel so many many
people use their Prime account to
subscribe to the Twitch account it was
so great and some people have been
staying over there uh watching this um
so that that is that is a that is
reassuring that you guys really do um
rather rather you love me or love to
hate me uh you are here to listen to
this show and this messaging and it's
important for you to listen to it in the
way that you do so I I appreciate all
that support that you gave through the
Bandit mention and I I really appreciate
everyone coming back to these platforms
as the bands and the suspensions were
lifted from Facebook and YouTube and you
guys are the greatest audience in the
world we have the greatest mods in the
world I got the greatest team in the
world behind me in the [__] up fam you
guys are the greatest over on Discord
whether you're here in the YouTube chat
if you're on Facebook or the Facebook
group Trump is full of [__] or if you're
on Twitch or even now on Instagram or
wherever you're finding me on Twitter
when you guys engage with me you're the
greatest in the world I hope you do have
a safe and happy holiday whether you
celebrate Christmas or not I hope it is
safe and it is great I hope you get to
spend time with your family and your
friends and you get a little time off a
little time uh away from reality because
reality right now is wild it's crazy out
there Grandpa Grandpa Hitler has been
quoting from minec comp for a while now
it's been a while since he's been
quoting from
minec not not just like last
[Music]
week it wasn't it wasn't just it wasn't
just the other day he's been saying the
blood poisoning stuff for a while now
and I believe it's because people are
telling him this is the [__] he should
be saying because they're telling him
look you need to ratchet up your
rhetoric because you need to really get
your base to be [__] [__] frothing at
the mouth and violent um and the reason
why is because they're really trying to
fend off these primary
Challengers um a lot of people have been
talking about Nikki Haley saying that
Nikki Haley is in on this Supreme Court
thing somehow and it's the Republicans
trying to choose her as the [__]
nominee if anyone is telling you that
Nikki Haley is going to be the
republican nominees stop listening to
them stop that's the dumbest [__] I've
ever heard
that you you fundamentally do not
understand how political money and
elections and primaries work if you
think Nikki Haley is going to win this
primary Holy
[__] Nikki Haley has to win New
Hampshire she has to win South Carolina
she has to if she does not win those
she's [__] now Ronda santis is the
only one that if they do keep Trump off
ballots which they will not be able to
keep him off all the ballots but if they
do keep him off ballots Ronda santis is
the only one that has a shot in
Hell against the other Challengers
because VC radad ding dong is obviously
a plant for Trump I mean he's like I'm
running for president please vote for
Donald Trump I mean that's literally
what what V is saying I mean not
literally he's he's basically saying it
though he's basically telling us hey I'm
running for president of the United
States please vote for Donald J Trump
like that's what he's saying He even
wears the truth hat with the truth
social it's [__] almost like he's
being
paid to be a plant for Trump now Chris
Christie is already at on the outs Chris
Christie cannot win this primary because
MAA will not support him at the
convention they won't do it it's not
gonna happen not gonna happen now let's
go back to the money in politics I
explained this this the other day
because a lot of people are bringing up
that the Coke brothers and a lot of the
big money donors have left Ronda santz
and went to Nikki Haley and that is an
indication that she might be the nominee
the problem is is that Nikki Haley is
spending money to be the second to Ronda
santis that money is being
used on killing Ronda Santos's
campaign masterly I might add the
problem is is when Rhonda s loses right
because this is Nikki Haley's
thought and this is the big money
donor's thought is that man if we could
just get
someone to scrape in Nikki Haley's vote
which is Chris Christie that's why Chris
Christie's out being like oh you should
not talk to this woman like that and I
will defend Nikki Haley
and gather up her support to support
me
and if you don't see that what you're
not getting how Republican politics work
they're not going to nominate a woman to
the top of the
ticket they're not they're not going to
do that especially not Nikki Haley I
don't know if you know this Nikki Haley
is really bad at this she's horrible at
it horribly horribly bad at presidential
retail politics
she's bad at
it she's really bad at it now I will say
that if Trump does get off these ballots
which I don't think he's going to be off
all the ballots there may be a few
ballots that he's doesn't appear on
because of the courts but he is if he is
off all these ballots if the Republicans
really wanted to beat Joe Biden and they
wanted to win they would nominate Chris
Christie Chris Christie is the best the
best political Juggernaut in that side
of the race other than Trump's having
his cult um to beat him but you know
that's that's how that's how it works so
this idea that Nikki Haley and somehow
they're trying to ju position to get
Niki Haley to be the nominee is really
[__] dumb it's really [__] dumb
now a lot of people point out because
manga's really upset about this Supreme
Court decision and they're really upset
because it's destroying democracy even
though they're the ones that are like
this isn't a democracy it's a
republic I heard this last night so I
went into Mario's room Mario Neal on
Twitter because like oh my God I want to
go listen to these [__] cry oh
it was so great oh my God they are such
[__]
crybabies I mean can you imagine can you
imagine if these manga idiots could use
the courts to take Joe Biden off ballots
oh my God they'd be like yeah this is
how it works and and we would be like
that's that's not democracy you can't do
that that's undemocratic that's that's
what the the left would do if they were
trying to take Joe Biden off the the
balance that's what they that's what we
do about the stupid impeachment thing
like that's what we do that's what we do
right because it's
stupid huh maybe there's maybe there's
something maybe there's something to it
I I don't know maybe we should have the
same same [__] feelings and same
thought if we had principles
on the same thing you know what I mean
it's almost like we should just ground
ourselves in principles and then stand
behind those principle I don't know
maybe maybe just maybe anyways I digress
from that but they would be frothing at
the mouth and they would be so excited
if they could keep Joe Biden off balance
with the courts oh they love the courts
and and we'd be like that's not
democracy and they'd be like it's not a
democracy it's a republic duh like that
would be the if we reversed it do you
ever think about that oh man oh man oh
oh [__] whoa whoa whoa whoa hang on hang
on I just came up with a great idea
maybe that's how we should look at this
I mean they're trying to impeach Joe
Biden they're saying he's committing an
Insurrection down at the southern B
border which is a bunch of [__] it's
a [__] lie he's never been indicted
on anything he's never been [__] they
don't even have evidence on him really
but what does that matter what does that
matter what I mean the 14th Amendment
clearly lays out if you think if you
think he's committed Insurrection and
you gather up enough enough evidence to
to convince a couple judges that he's
done that then you can get it kicked to
the Supreme Court and maybe the Supreme
Court make the decision that you
want listen to
yourself listen
ground yourself in
principles do that
first then look through the lens of
those principles and continue to look
through the lens of those
principles if you don't
think that these [__] Nazis will take
advantage anywhere they can and if we
give them advantages they're going to
take
them they're going to take
them and they're going to use them for
all kinds of bad
[__] and just because Trump's gone
doesn't mean that these fascists aren't
gone
folks Trump is a symptom of the
disease he's a
symptom they're not going to stop it
doesn't matter how many [__] ballots
you take him on
off it doesn't matter if you don't
[__] want him to be the nominee it
doesn't
matter and if it ain't Trump it'll be
another [__]
idiot that's why I argue about the
[__] Liz Cheney the Adam kinzinger
the Paul Ryan the Mitt Romney because
when they get their Republican party
back they're going to do the same old
[__] they did to create Trump same old
[__] they're going to do the same old
[__]
so so just do the thing that you should
do and do democracy do that grab your
principles stick with your principles
and use those principles as the
foundation of our our pro-democracy
Coalition and let's do the work let's
[__] do the work it's tough It's hard
but that's called democracy democracy
isn't easy folks it's difficult
democracy is not for [__] weak
people it's not democracy devours weak
people that's why you have all the
[__] mangas crying and whining that a
court made a decision because this the
Colorado Supreme Court totally has the
right to make this decision I don't know
if MAA has found this out yet but it was
Republicans who brought this case not
Democrats Democrats weren't trying to
keep Donald Trump off the bout the
reason why is because Democrats have no
stake in the Republican primary ballot
dummy you have to have Merit you have to
have standing in a case okay for the
court to even hear your case you got to
have standing and there's no standing
for Democrats taking Trump off a
Republican primary
ballot they have no
standing in that they have no standing
that's going to be the challenge with
the general election ballots don't you
see don't you
see you're going to have really [__]
hard trouble with general election
ballots the reason why they were able to
bring this case in the first place is
because Republicans have standing to
keep him off the ballot in
Colorado and they always knew I knew you
knew I told you that this was always
going to go to the Supreme Court it's
not going to stop at a lower court
everyone's just going to be like yeah
that's cool no problem we'll just keep
him off the
ballot that wasn't going to
happen it was always going to be the
Supreme Court deciding this
issue
always so keep that in
mind as you're typing in stuff and
you're saying stuff out loud
because the right and MAA says really
dumb [__] all the time like you can
count on it like [__] I don't have
enough time and I do this show two hours
a day I have enough time to [__] show
you all the dumb [__] they say it's wild
and crazy some of the dumb [__] they
say and sometimes I just think they're
just saying dumb [__] just to say dumb
[__] they're like how [__] stupid can
we be and get away with it like that's
their
mission don't don't what they do don't
do that don't say [__] like oh well
listen to this if the Supreme Court
decides to keep Trump on the ballot then
that means Joe Biden can be president
forever that is not what it means Joe
Biden is not on a Republican primary
ticket he's he's not Joe Biden will
never ever ever ever appear on a
Republican primary ballot in
Colorado and of course Lincoln project
and several others and it was a joke
it's a gag it's a goof I get
it they were like Joe Biden wins
Colorado which Joe Biden's gonna win
Colorado the reason why Joe Biden's
gonna win Colorado is because he won it
last time and the math hasn't
changed he won it in 2020 handily and
the Math's Not Gonna Change that's why
Joe Biden is going to be president of
the United States he's going to win this
election because the math just hasn't
changed that much and that's kind of how
elections work it's math uh uh uh you
got a certain amount of votes versus a
certain amount of votes I don't know if
you know that it's kind of like math
just we got to get everyone to engage
and turn out it's all we got to
do and we will beat Donald Trump we do
not have to [__] rely on the courts
to take him off any ballots even
Republican primary ballots
because again it's a primary ballot that
they are asking the question on and it's
Republicans bringing this case against
Donald Trump because it's Republicans in
Colorado that have
standing on their
ballot so the right's like oh this is
Democrats taking away your
democracy nope it was Republicans doing
this and it is going to be a
conservative court with three three
picks from Donald Trump on
it okay it's not it's not Democrats
doing this and to the
left just because the Supreme Court and
it is very likely that they will rule in
favor of Donald Trump doesn't mean Joe
Biden will be president forever that
would mean he would have to commit an
Insurrection the problem is is that Joe
Biden is never going to
try to do a
coup if Joe Biden's had an opportunity
to do a coup in 2016 like the same type
of coup like he could have CED like MAA
couped you know what I mean oh my God he
could have yeah [__] yeah Joe Biden was
the vice
president in 2016 so in January 2017 Joe
Biden could have said you know what that
fake elector scheme that sounds great
we're gonna coup that way and I'm just
gonna [__] make Hillary Clinton the
goddamn president of the United
States that's that's exactly what he
could have
done but he he he didn't he's not he's
not gonna do
that okay he's he's not gonna do he's
not gonna he's not he's not going to
commit an
insurrection
it's not going to happen that way okay
so keep your [__] panties out of a
wad all
right just because the Supreme Court
decides that in favor of Donald Trump
which they are likely to do here I hate
to break it to you it is way more likely
that they're going to side with Trump on
this than not and the biggest reason
why biggest reason
why is because he has not been
charged and he has not been convicted of
insurrection as much as he should have
been charged and as much as he should be
[__]
convicted of insurrection because he
definitely did it but
that's a feeling isn't how we do law we
don't do law by feeling it's not how we
do it this country that's not Justice um
and it's not Justice if I don't show you
this clip of
him talking about about
minec oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy listen Grandpa Hitler the one thing
you don't want to do is stand on stage
when people are accusing you of wanting
to be a dictator and
then you've been reading from MC off the
teleprompter no matter who put it there
it doesn't matter if you put it on the
tele prompter or Steven Miller put it on
teleprompter someone put it on a
teleprompter someone wrote that [__] in
there but you really shouldn't say the
word mind comp like in front of a
microphone if you're going to read from
it but you know it is Trump so let him
keep talking like he's His Own Worst
Enemy this is how we're going to beat
him right here listen it's crazy what's
going on they're ruining our country and
it's true they're destroying the blood
of our country that's what they're doing
they're destroying our country they
don't like it when I said that and I
never read mine
comp did you hear the pronunciation of
it too holy [__] man it's almost like
he's scared that the ghost of Hitler
will strike him dead if he doesn't
pronounce it just
correctly like listen to it listen
listen again let me let me get it back
there let me go go back to it listen I'm
doing this view because I want you guys
to see the uh the nice Christmas
background that I got going on because I
I want everyone to know that I'm not
afraid to say Merry Christmas that the
the righties are like oh you want you're
trying to make it to where no one says
Merry
Christmas so I want you to see my
Christmas background I'm not even I'm an
atheist I'm not even a Christian anymore
I was raised Catholic and and you know
Catholics make some of the best atheist
right and I think all the whole religion
thing is really stupid but that's my
personal opinion um you know I'm not
going to shame anybody else for their
beliefs it's whatever you want to do
whatever you want to have I'll tell you
my beliefs and you can tell me your
beliefs but you know but here's the
thing is that my Christmas background is
just a just a piss the right off but I
like it I like the Christmas Ma it's
very festive all right let's listen to
him listen to his anun
of the book listen blood of our country
that's what they're doing they're
destroying our country they don't like
it when I said that and I never read
mine comp I never read mine
comp he knows there's an F on the
end do you think that's what it is he's
terrified it's like it's it's like
Christmas Carol with the Ghost of
Christmas Past and he's scared that like
the G the the Ghost of Christmas Past
will come and visit him and he'll have
have a little bitty mustache you know
what I mean that's what I feel like it
is he's like man I really got to make
sure to get this
right but here is here here's here's the
rest of his statement about how he loves
Hitler they said oh Hitler said
[Laughter]
that Hitler did say that dude he Hitler
Hitler did say that Grandpa Hitler oh my
God I can't I mean honestly I I don't
even know why people are [__] worried
about this 14th Amendment thing like why
are you even [__] worried about it
who gives a [__] like this is like this
dude this dude I mean listen listen when
Grandpa Hitler says something you have
to always start at whatever he says is a
[__] lie like that's where you start
that's where you start with him whenever
he says something out loud you always
start with okay this has got to be a lie
and then you got to work back to is he
actually telling the truth here could he
be telling the truth listen listen
destroying our country they don't like
it when I said that and I never read
mine comp they said oh Hitler said that
in a much different way a much different
way yeah he said it in German I mean
what he said it in much different way no
no no he didn't say it in a different
way he said it in a different language
if that's what the [__] you mean oh my
God listen he definitely 100% has had
someone read mcom to him rather he knows
it or
not whether he knows it or not Stephen
Miller has read minec to him has put
minec on his teleprompter for him to say
out
loud and we worried about him being on
ballots are you serious okay all right
all right no they're coming from all
over the world people all over the world
world we have no idea they could be
healthy they could be very unhealthy
they could bring in disease that's going
to catch on in our country but they do
bring in crime but they have them coming
from all over the world uh you forgot
the hooknose part there Grandpa you forg
Hitler if you're going to get it get it
in there like get it in there the
disease the the the healthy unhealthy
right right like he's he's saying Vermin
remember he said ver
he called us verman remember that also
is you know has the stench of musolini
and mind
com he said it in a different way like
in German my God Jesus
Christ and you're worried about beating
this guy are you are you [__] kidding me
kidding me you're worried about beating
him okay all right all right listen he
was he was easy to beat last
time Joe Biden beat him by the biggest
margin
ever it was the highest turnout ever too
and he beat him by almost eight million
votes eight million almost two and a
half times what Hillary Clinton beat him
in the popular vote
by let me say that again Donald Trump
lost to Hillary Clinton in the popular
vote by 3 million almost 3 million Joe
Biden beat him by almost 8 million
votes two and a half
times okay and now he's quoting and
saying he wants to be a
dictator and he's quoting from mine comp
and then he's saying yeah I'm voting for
mine comp but I haven't read it he
didn't say any what he didn't quote from
my here let me play it again he didn't
say he didn't quote from it okay it's
not that's not what he said it's not
what he said what he said was is he
hasn't read it yeah he quoted from it
but he hasn't read it listen it's crazy
what's going on they're ruining our
country and it's true they're destroying
the blood of our country that's what
they're doing they're destroying our
country they don't like it when I said
that and I never read mine comp I never
read it I never read it I mean I just
[__] repeated it okay I never read
the book I just had someone pick out
phrases in there and I put them in a
speech and I read him out loud they said
oh Hitler said that he did say that in a
much different way in
German oh I God he's so stupid keep
saying it keep [__] saying
it keep saying it dummy keep saying it
um there is a new a new Trump GIF that
has dropped though uh Aaron rupar made
sure to point this out this is a new
Trump gift I want you guys to see this
so you can get this going
Dr
Dr Drill
drill drill
drill oh
goddamn he definitely he definitely has
imagery down doesn't
he oh [__] I got another good one I got
a another good one for Donnie dict
taster here hang on on hang on with me
it's a hilarious one too it's a clip
from last night let me show you this one
too the the Biden Harris campaign their
the Twitter account Biden Harris HQ
their Campaign Headquarters posted this
one listen to this uh first off I wantan
to remember we played the uh the
commercial of trumpy bear remember that
and it that that commercial feels like
it's not real like I could play the
trumpy bear commercial as a satire
commercial on the show and people would
laugh at it and think that it's satire
but it's [__] real it's [__] real
but look at here the trumpinator teddy
bear they have they have a
trumpinator oh my
God we live in the dumbest [__]
timeline ever oh my God and and you
think we can't beat this guy we need the
courts to 14th him what the [__] are you
talking look at this [__] they're buying
trumpinator teddy bears
[Laughter]
folks oh [__] oh [__] all right well
listen to the clip oh man go ahead they
say I'm a threat to democracy they say
I'm a threat to democracy yeah people
are saying that people are saying people
are saying Grandpa Hitler go ahead what
was that they say I'm a threat to
democracy they say I'm a threat to
democracy a lot of people are saying
what the French
call A lot of people are saying a lot of
people are saying that I'm a threat to
democracy so many people so many so many
democracy that is what they're
[Laughter]
saying do you think he works this [__]
out in front of a mirror do you think
oh my God I can't with this
[__] oh man that's incredible
it's some great clips from last night
he's jacking off he's saying people are
saying I'm a threat to democracy people
are saying that they're saying that yeah
we are saying that the best part is
again his
H his followers and MAA are like yeah
yeah you Democrats are trying to undo
democracy like it's a republic that's
when I want to yell back at him it's a
republic um speaking of saying dumb [__]
see if you can make out what he says in
this clip what is he talking about
listen here I'm driving over a road
where it's almost all paper garbage and
you know you can see paper I know paper
I know cans you know P do you know paper
do you know cans I know paper and cans
you know they're a good time they're
they're fun to hang out with you know
paper and cans they like to drink they
like to do drugs a lot of times they
they'll have some [__] you know Manaj
[__] orgies type things they're really
cool people those those papers and cans
what the [__] is he talking about let me
back it up number one let's listen I'm
driving over a road you're driving over
a road when's the last time you think
this [__] has
driven like behind the wheel of a car
like actually
driveing when's the last time actually
this isn't how you
drive this isn't how you drive you drive
like
this or or like this you don't drive
this I don't because if you're driving
like that the car would be like you know
what I mean I'm just saying that that
motion doesn't really
work but when's the last time this
[__] was driving ever he's never
driven what are you talking about
Drive okay but then the next part gets
weirder he's doing what where it's
almost all paper garbage and you know
you can see paper I know paper I know
cans I know paper I know cans is he
talking about because there's like trash
on the side of the highway is that what
he's talking
about what the [__] does this what I
mean yeah so let's do adop the highway
type
thing like that's what most [__]
states do is they do an adopt the
highway thing he does know that the
states are responsible for keeping the
roads done not the federal government
right the federal government gives the
states money for the roads to you know
to like keep them up make sure there's
not trash all over the place but what is
he he knows paper I know paper I know
cans I know them they're so great so
great people are saying that they're
getting better paper and cans paper and
cans and you're worried about beating
him okay when cans start to literally
rot I'm
driving cans start to literally
rot cans are made of aluminum folks
cans are made of
[Laughter]
aluminum aluminum Al aluminum
doesn't
rot what the [__] oh my but he knows
them he knows can so well he knows what
they're made of he knows what they made
of he knows what the cans are made of
and he knows that they rot even though
cans don't cans don't don't rot they
they don't what what are you talking
about like eventually over time you know
they'll
degrade what the [__] is he talking
about and and the degraded cans that are
pounded into the [__] ground you
can't see those ones so you don't know
that they're
there and then he's worried about the
paper right is the paper rotting too
grandpa is that is the paper rotting
he's not worried about the plastic no
[__] the plastic plastic good plastic
good good plastic good paper
aluminum
aluminum cans bad bad
stuff wow
wow oh
wow uh we got Shaz in the chat today uh
and he's changed his mind on DeSantis
because DeSantis sounds like an idiot
you remember that the other day you
remember that the other day when Shaz
told us in the chat you remember that
because Shaz is the perfect example of a
[__] [__] eat a [__] eater perfect
example like like he just every single
time he does exactly what I know he's
gonna do and he's gonna do it this time
too he's gonna do it this time too so
Shaz told us the other day that um
DeSantis sounds really stupid he doesn't
know how to talk he does know what he's
talking about sounds like J Bush he's an
idiot is what what he was saying now he
used to be for the santis right oh he
loved the santis until Donald Trump said
he was a dict taster right I I didn't
say I want to be a dict taster I just
said I want to be a dict taster on day
one and then Shaz is like oh yeah give
me some of that dick taster that's
[__] awesome so he switchs from the
Florida fascist D
santis to the dictate Donnie dict taster
right grandpa Hitler [__] Chaz loves him
some [__] Nazis [__] Grandpa
Hitler's the team that he's on now but
he told us the reason why he wanted to
leave DeSantis is because DeSantis sound
stupid but does this sound stupid to you
is this sound stupid listen I'm driving
over a road where it's almost all paper
garbage and you know you can see paper I
know paper paper I know cans I know
paper I know cans when cans start to
literally rot literally rot which they
don't literally do that hey shz hey shz
you're are you going to go um have to um
be a Nicki Haley fan now because Trump
sounds like a [__] idiot just like
Ronda Sanz huh huh are you gonna stay
grounded in your principles I highly
[__] doubt
it oh do you see how easy he's going to
be to beat like literally he's gonna be
so [__] easy to beat it's going to be
so easy so easy all right let me show
you um maybe maybe Shaz will go like
this guy the ve ramama damama ding
dong pronounce my name
correctly ramama damama dingdong here H
this is his take on the Colorado ballot
debacle now remember they're going to
print they have to print they have to
start printing the Republican primary
ballots on January 5th got it January
5th January
5th is when they print the Republican
primary ballots that they're trying to
keep Trump off of okay it's December
20th I just want to remind you that
we're two weeks away a little over two
weeks away from them printing these
ballots okay remember that now all these
these candidates including rad damama
dingdong here has made sure to get
themselves on the Colorado ballot ballot
the primary bout which they're trying to
keep Trump off of not the general
election boutot the primary boutot that
will be printed on January 5th okay now
this is V stance on the Colorado
decision listen to this stupid [__] I'm
making a pledge today that I will
withdraw I pledge to withdraw from the
the Colorado GOP Primary ballot unless
and until TR Trump's name is
restored and I demand that Ronda sanis
and Chris Christie and Nikki Haley do
the same
thing I demand he demands R Dam ding
dong says and it comes true this is so
dumb what you're gonna take your name
off the ballot because the Supreme Court
May or may not decide to be on the bout
listen to this all
right they're going to print them on
January 5th all right the 5th we got
Christmas and New Year's in between the
Supreme Court has to agree to take this
case and they have to make a decision on
this case so the Colorado secretary of
state knows whether to print Trump's
name on The Ballot or not and Trust me
on January 5th whatever the decision is
from the Supreme Court it does not
matter whatever that decision is the
Secretary of State in Colorado will
follow that decision okay
period
period now this dumb [__] is saying that
what he wants to do in the leadup to
it is to voluntarily take himself
off the ballot and he's demanding
demanding demanding that Nikki
Haley Chris Christie and Ronda santis
demanding that they take their names off
the ballot as well between now and
January
5th VC radama dingdong here is betting
that Trump's going to be back on the
ballot folks he's betting on
it and he's getting himself and he's
demanding that they get themselves off
the ballot because what they want
because rad damama dingdong here is is
is in it for Trump he's a trump plant
he's not actually running for president
he's acting like he's running for
president to help
Trump because what he's doing is he's
sucking up votes I don't know if you
know that he's sucking up votes in the
primary that's what rad damama ding
Dong's doing he's sucking up the votes
in the primary and then he'll drop out
after Trump wins
okay you got it do you see it are you
seeing it yet you see how it works he's
making sure to take away votes from
Ronda
santz he's trying to take votes away
from Ronda santis so that way Donald
Trump can
win oh my
God but he demands he demands at the
other candidates take their name off The
Ballot or else these Republicans are
simply complicit in this constitutional
attack on the way we conduct our
constitutional republic I refuse to be
complicit in that I think what they're
doing is wrong and I think it's up to
Republicans to step up and stand up with
a spine for our country's future that's
really what's at stake it's the
Republicans who brought this case you
[__]
bonehead they're the only ones that have
standing in Colorado for the Republican
primary ballot is Republicans r damama
ding dong what a [__] idiot holy [__]
now I have to admit I have to admit that
V knows who he's talking to if you
notice that did you notice he knows who
he's talking to let me back it up just a
bit here let me back it
up right there I think all right let's
let's listen and Chris Christie and
Nikki Haley do the same thing or else
these Republicans are simply complicit
in this unconstitutional attack on the
way we conduct cond our constitutional
republic on the way that we conduct our
constitutional republic so he didn't do
the stupid thing where he's like our
democracy the Democrats are attacking
our democracy when in the same breath
he' be like it ain't a democracy it's a
republic so he knows who he's talking to
right that's one thing rad damama
dingdong is very [__] good at he is
talking to the online incels that are in
your comment section that's who he's
talking to that's who his voters
are and that's why he's trying to peel
them away from Ronda
santz he's trying to peel him away from
there I'm surprised Shaz didn't get on
the on the ramama damn ding-dong train I
mean I know he's on the ding-dong train
why didn't he get on the ram Dam
dingdong train I don't know maybe he
will maybe he'll flip because Trump says
stupid [__] but let's let's listen to
the rest of rad damama dingdong ramble
I refuse to be complicit in that I think
what they're doing is wrong and I think
it's up to Republicans to step up and
stand up with a spine for our country's
future that's really what's at stake
whether we the people actually have a
say in deciding who leads this country
yes it would be easier for other
Republicans like me who are running in
this race to say hey if Trump is
sideline there's our opportunity no
doubt other candidates are probably
privately celebrating with their
corporate sponsors that's not the right
thing to do with their corporate
sponsors here's a guy who's taking all
kinds of corporate money and he's
talking about corporate sponsors what a
lion sack of [__] I think the most
useful thing that every GOP candidate
can do right now is to join me in that
pledge I'll say that I will withdraw
from that Colorado GOP Primary ballot
until Trump's name is restored this
belongs to the people not to the
unelected Democratic cabal of judges in
Colorado or any other state they are
elected hey hey the Supreme Court
justices in Colorado hey hey hey hey rad
damama dingdong it's democracy over
there they're
elected how don't these [__] people
how don't they know this [__] how don't
they know this stuff how don't they know
this [__] how how how how and why does
anyone take them seriously when they say
this
trash that's why I can't take people
seriously now last night on on Twitter
who said that [__] that oh if Trump wins
this decision then Biden can be
president forever no that would assume
that Biden committed an Insurrection and
he's not going to do that it's dumb it's
dumb it's dumb and and and and the
actual the actual thing that the law
does is is doesn't doesn't assume that
every president is going to be a
dictator or or commit an
Insurrection it's a [__] crime to
commit an Insurrection it's a [__]
federal crime
okay oh my God oh my God it's just dumb
[__] it's just dumb
[__] just it's really stupid
stuff and and and again I I know I know
a lot of people are not GNA like when I
say this uh a couple more times but
Trump derangement syndrome is real Biden
derangement syndrome is real most of the
country does not have it the majority of
the country does not have Trump
derangement syndrome or Biden
derangement syndrome stop acting like
they do stop acting like it and stop
stop stop engaging in democracy like
they do stop that that's dumb I'll tell
you what's what's not dumb you want to
see a real piece of news about you talk
about Insurrection an Insurrection news
you want to see a real pie piece of
news like a real piece of legal news
that's a huge piece of legal news
because really honestly a lot of people
were surmising last night which again
this is the stupid
snowball and this is why the 14th
Amendment thing these people bringing
the people bringing all the 14th
Amendment cases against trump it it it
it it's all because of him not because
they have some sort of [__] grounding
in the constitu
principles that they're espousing it's
him it's it's him they have derangement
syndrome and it's him it ain't about
their constitutional principles it's not
it's
not big step fan is always all over my
[__] method to my madness you
teas hey big step you're here every day
for two hours and I I can count on you
you're you're a great a great listener
and you're here every day and you're so
engaged in the show you've been here for
such a long time and I appreciate you
being over on Twitch and and keeping it
Lively over there I really do Merry
Christmas to you if you celebrate
Christmas if you don't happy holidays
whatever whatever doesn't offend you and
I know I can't filthy animal I know I
can't offend big Steph um um very much
but here's the thing is I I have to keep
folks
listening for two hours there are
certain things that a host has to do um
one of the things is is to entertain you
can you imagine if I just sat here and
was boring and just like okay um so um
the next thing we're gonna talk about um
so I really what what do you what do you
guys think the next thing I should talk
about is huh let's let's let's crowd
Source what this show is going to be
about today why don't you tell me what
you want to hear and then I'll say it
okay that'll be great if you just type
in what you want me to say like no it's
got to be entertained it's got to have a
pace to it it can't have a lot of dead
air the last several weeks I and and and
I appreciate the rat song I'm Gonna Play
rat's Christmas song um that he made for
me yes I'm going to play that too yes
I'm teasing it um big step
fan but but um here's the thing is that
I hate dead air I [__] hate it rat
knows I hate it I hate dead air I don't
stop talking the whole time if I do
pause there's a reason for it and I
don't like muting my mic if I don't have
to but I've had that cough and it's
getting better if you notice it's
getting better I've only had a couple
instances today where I had to cough and
I was able to do it when a video was
playing so I can mute and cough and you
guys didn't notice it much because I
don't like dead air I think it makes it
to where the show
[Laughter]
sucks it
sucks so so what I do what what um so
because I've had to cough and I had to
pause that's the reason why why rat
goofed on me with the song and I loved
it I love the Goof I think it's so funny
um I like self-deprecating humor I think
it's great we we all got a goof on each
other and that's why I like big step fan
because big step fan is always over
there um in in twitch goofing and and I
love I love goofing I love big goofing
so thank you big Steph fan for being
here as you have you're like OG over on
Twitch and yes I did tease you but now I
will give you the pleasure here of the
news K cheny reports this yesterday
chief judge
bosenberg bosenberg I don't know I don't
read worth of [__] has ordered
representative Scott Perry do you
remember Scott Perry folks do you
remember Scott Perry that [__] sedici
traitor he is a he's a congressman from
Pennsylvania Scott Perry was the one
pushing the fake State elector scheme in
Pennsylvania that's right it was him and
if Pennsylvania brings charges like in
Michigan and Arizona more likely in
Georgia then Scott Perry will go to
jail huh it's a funny thing when you
commit crimes Scott you [__]
[__] now uh the judges ordered Scott
Perry to turn over
1650 emails and text
uhoh he is sought to shield from federal
prosecutors Scott Perry does not want
Jack Smith or other Federal prosecutors
including in
Pennsylvania but especially the special
Council because special Council has
power in Pennsylvania now he does not
want them to see 1650 emails and text
now this is a vast majority of the
255 five that judge Hal previously
ordered Perry to disclose but which was
halted by the court of
appeals now this
folks this is a court case that is
real this is a court decision that has
real [__] consequences for the
Insurrection real [__] consequences
now I want to go back to the 14th thing
real quick quick if the people who are
pushing the 14th Amendment [__] if
they really were trying to 14th and it
was principle it was principle that they
were standing on they would have cases
against all these people in the Congress
and the Senate they would have court
cases they would be trying to work their
way through Court they'd be trying to
work their way up to the Supreme Court
but they're not doing
that they're
not they're not doing that they're not
doing
it that's because their idea the 14th
Amendment is not grounded in in there it
is not grounded in principle of the
Insurrection Clause okay because there
is just as much evidence that Scott
Perry here has done just as much
Insurrection as Donald
Trump where's the 14th amender on this
where are
they where are they but the good news is
is we don't need the 14th Scott Perry
because it looks like Scott Perry is
gonna 14th himself kind of like George
Santos
did kind of I mean not the same way
George Santos stole money and credit
card numbers and committed fraud Scott
Perry was trying to commit fraud by
stealing our election and our
votes little different
little different but kind of the same
it's still a federal crime to do that
[__] oh Scott Perry You're so [__] you
are so
[__] because these 1650
emails are definitely definitely
definitely tied to January 6 and
definitely tied to the state elector
scheme the fake State elector scheme in
Pennsylvania because I've been telling
you all along Georgia Arizona Nevada pen
Pennsylvania Wisconsin and Michigan
those are the states to look at to see
prosecutions for the the fake State
elector scheme we already have
prosecutions in Georgia we have charges
in in Michigan and we have charges in
Nevada the only ones we're waiting on is
Pennsylvania Arizona and Wisconsin those
are the three that we're waiting on and
if you remember if you remember Senator
Ron Johnson was the one that was trying
to be part of the fake State elector
scheme and getting those fake electors
in Mike Pence's hand on January 6 and if
you know anything about politics and who
senators in what state Ron Johnson is
the sen is the state senator you United
States senator from
Wisconsin yep but Scott Perry here is
completely [__] because this means
that these, 1600 50 emails are going to
get into the
lap of Jack Smith more
importantly they can be used by Jack
Smith they cannot be shielded from the
federal prosecutors because my guess is
Jack Smith already has a cash of these
emails on the other side see that's the
funny part about a text or an email a
text or an email Isn't
one-sided they're two-sided
so you got the one side that sends it
and the one side that receives it so
it's very
likely that Jack Smith already knows
about a lot of these emails and texts he
already knows about them he's got them
on the other side you see what I mean
he's got the second side of
it whoosh it's incredible that these
criminals don't know that um but this is
a real big piece of I mean this is a um
very very big and um here's more of this
reporting uh Kyle Cheney goes on here
the judge found that the vast majority
of Perry's contacts were not legislative
in nature because that's how he was
trying to Shield them and that's how the
the court of
appeals uh made their their um their
judgment in Perry's favor particularly
the ones that he was lobbing the
executive branch and the PA legislators
to take steps to alter election outcome
holy [__] so this
judge this judge is Sayang out loud hey
there's emails and
text that Perry was was lobbying the
executive branch and Pennsylvania
legislators to alter the election
outcome otherwise he would not be saying
this in this legal decision Perry's
discussions of Pence's January 6 role
also dis closable meaning that that
Perry's um view on Pence giving him the
because that's what that's what Perry's
job actually was here on January 6 was
to hand he had those that fake slate of
electors ready to hand to Mike Pence
when Mike Pence decided to make Donald
Trump the
dictator he had him ready he was ready
Ron Johnson was ready Scott Perry was
ready they were ready with those State
electors to hand to Mike Pence when he
decided to overturn our election and
turn us into
autocracy that that that that's called
Insurrection that's that's that's
treasonous okay but this is this is it's
very clear that Perry's plan was the
fake State electors and Pence's role in
that on January 6 and it exists inside
these emails and text
otherwise they wouldn't be saying this
out loud in
court they're they're saying out loud
hey these text and emails have to do
with the Mike Pence
scheme
so rro um here's a little more reporting
on this because I I'm telling you this
is really big news this is really
[__] important um Kyle goes on here
Perry has not yet decided if his he will
appeal the ruling that his attorney says
if the decision holds it will be
significant infusion of new evidence for
Jack
Smith as he seeks to keep Trump's DC
trial on track now this is one problem
that I have with Jack Smith and the and
the trial the DC trial is that if Jack
Smith has this evidence and he doesn't
do a superseding indictment to include
this member of Congress it is a
dereliction in his
duty that's right I'm going to to say it
out loud if Jack Smith has the evidence
to charge Perry in this conspiracy with
Donald Trump and he does not do a suping
indictment to include Perry in that
conspiracy it is a dereliction of his
duty all Jack Smith is doing is trying
to make sure Trump doesn't become
president he's not trying to he's not
trying to [__] prosecute him if
that's the case that's my that's my
opinion it's my
opinion but this is huge news this is
huge news because this means that Perry
can't hide his seditious emails and and
text anymore and he can't hide the
evidence of uh his his role in the
Insurrection on January 6 he can't do it
um so I I appreciate Kyle always staying
on top of that reporting and that's
that's a huge huge huge piece of of
legal news that's actually news um that
could make a huge difference uh
in in knowing what actually happened on
January 6
um uh those are those are I want to show
you those two clips how much time we got
we got a half an
hour oh we got a half an hour I got
those clips I I don't I don't want to
skip around um little dick energy type
news I know this isn't as big of news
because you know I mean we all know Ted
Cruz doesn't have big news you know what
I mean I mean come
on if you think if you think this guy's
walking around with a big fat hog you're
come on he ain't no Hunter Biden for
crying out loud right he ain't no Hunter
Biden now Ted Cruz went to this turning
points USA um Nazi fua this fascist
phoa okay he went to that thing and he
spoke at it now remember he speaking to
a bunch of really young people you know
these are 18 19 20 year old women and
boys if you watch the video of this
they're not men they're they're boys but
anyways here's what he said in front of
a bunch of young people this is weird
stuff but listen to it left is so bad
they're so unhappy they're so pissed off
and by the
way if you were a liberal
woman and you had to sleep with those
weenies what are you what is he saying
that liberal men are bad at [__] or
is he saying they have little
dicks which one is he saying here you
think you think he's but you know it's
kind of weird that as soon as soon as
they're talking about the left being mad
he's like weeners dick dick dick dick
dick dick dick dick dick dick dick penis
penis penis penis penis penis penis he
he thinks more about penis than does
about his podcast I think what why do
they always go to genitalia why and why
is their favorite piece of genitality to
talk about is a [__] wiener
why
why he's in front of a crowd of young
people and the thing he talks about is
Dick and how big his dick is or how
small their dick I don't know
listen You' be pissed too
okay if you think first
off if you think your political
affiliation has anything to do with the
size of your [__] you're a dumb son of a
[__] first off all right first off I'm
sure there's plenty of [__]
Republicans out there that got a little
bitty teeny weeny and some of them got a
[__] a [__] chicken that hangs
down to their goddamn knees okay
political affiliation really has nothing
to do with the size of your C [__] all
right now let's move on from that
because that is weird right that is
weird but let's move on from that let's
say he's not talking about the size of
the [__] let's say he's talking about
how the guy uses
it all right if conservative
people if conservative people think that
they [__] better than liberal people
what the [__] are you talking about man
we are so we are so much more open into
sexual things than you
[__] so much more open than oh
[__] hell yeah that's the [__] that's
the that's kind of the I mean
politically liberal is one thing but if
you're liberal in general and you're
like open to things open to
Opportunities open to I don't know like
have fun things happen and just you know
the more sex the better like that's
that's the definition of
liberal if you think liberals who are
the sexual deviants of this country have
worse sex than
conservatives what the [__] are you
talking about man so either either Ted
Cruz is projecting about his idy Bey
teeny weenie and he can't stop thinking
about [__] or Ted Cruz is telling on
himself here and Heidi's a little
disappointed she's a little disappointed
just just I mean there's probably a lot
of
disappointment and really honestly now
that I'm thinking about it and saying it
out loud she's probably not disappointed
that Ted Cruz isn't that great in the
sack because that makes her not want to
have sex with him and really if you
think about it who in the [__] would
want to have sex with Ted Cruz all right
I'm moving on I'm moving on I'm just
saying it's really [__] weird
that these people go straight to
[__] straight to it they're like oh
there's young people in the room weener
weener weener weener weener it's really
[__] it's kind of weird I'm not gonna
lie all right uh let's see I'm gonna
make sure I I don't miss any Clips here
because I do want to um get tall these
did you guys like the George Soros
interview uh Easter egg I did yesterday
that was a great one was it I wasn't
able to play that clip on the show and I
didn't play you the whole clip oh my God
that interview is it's so [__] great
I don't know how a person can be so
goddamn vile and evil but so
entertaining on the same on the same
breath but he is but he is all right
speaking of weirdos that probably think
about Dick a lot um I want to show you
who has been reading mind com to Grandpa
Hitler yeah I actually don't think that
um Trump has actually sat down to read
mine comp that would actually mean he
would have to sit down to
read and read a
book yeah I don't think he's doing that
I think other people are giving him
these ideas right he he loves the idea
of Hitler he loves the idea of dictators
he loves the idea of authoritarians he
loves the idea of that his cult would
consider him a furer I mean [__] they
they they said that was telling the
generals when he was the president of
United States he wish the generals in
our
country would be more like Hitler's
generals he said that [__] he said that
[__] so what do you want from me but my
guess is is that it is someone else who
is writing the words of mine comp and
Hitler into his speeches and probably on
a daily basis feeding him a diet of Bine
comp and convincing him that he should U
use mine comp as his basis of policy um
but here is here is Stephen Miller
telling you he reads mcom uh to Grandpa
Hitler without telling you he reads mine
comp to Hitler let's listen to weirdo
GBL here you use the right word we are
being conquered this is a complete
resettlement of America in real time it
took hundreds of years
going back long even before our founding
going back all the way to the earliest
days of the colonies in America to
slowly build everything that we have and
now when you have millions of people
coming in from different cultures and
different ways of living in different
belief systems this is
minec this is
minec now again I I hate to have to keep
pointing this out but the uh the
translation of mine comp is my
struggle okay
it's the it's the vict Bible of
victimhood okay is what minec comp is my
struggle
oh I'm so inadequate I'm so inadequate
but my
inadequacy is caused by other people
that have nothing to do with
me it's it's a piece of whining there
what Nazis are whiny little [__]
including this guy but he is he's
basically telling you the underlying
tenaments of M conf here keep going
there Geral let's hear what you have to
say they're going to take those belief
systems with them to America so a
generation from now I am Telling You
Jesse people will not know the country
that they are living in these
consequences are permanent unless there
is massive large scale deportation
by the millions it will be
irrevocable again this is mind
comp tell me you're reading Grandpa
Hitler mind com without telling me
you're
reading Grandpa Hitler mind com holy
[__] man this guy again I know people
view this guy as a [__] joke and he
really is a fascist little [__] joke
right but I'm telling you this guy is
feeding Donald Trump Grandpa Hitler he's
feeding him a healthy diet of Nazi
propaganda he's feeding him a healthy
diet of MC we've been saying this for
years and years and years and the scary
part is is that [__] was in our
government in our government and he was
he was the one advocating putting
[__] children in cages and separating
families
guess who else did that in history guess
who
else I mean I can give you one guess
maybe I give you two but I bet you only
need [__]
one
whoosh so there's the more of the Mind
conf narrative and again I
listen Nick Adams posted a picture here
and this is definitely AI I don't know
if know who Nick Adams
is I don't know if you know who Nick
Adams is Nick
Adams declares himself an alpha male and
it's been a while since I've shown Nick
Adams [__] on on the show here so Nick
congratulations dummy you made it back
on the Tony Michaels podcast with your
stupid [__] with your stupid [__]
uh ai ai generated art here but I'm
going to show you why it's AI and you
can't believe it other than you know it
kind of looks like AI um but here's he
he's endorsed by Donald Trump
presidential Point Australian by birth
American by choice oh my God okay all
right here's this AI picture now here's
how you know that it's not real because
he is reading that's how you know it's
not real um this guy has never [__]
picked up a book but pay attention to
the book here do you see the book I wish
I could zoom in a little more let me see
if I can let me see if I can zoom in
just a bit more hang on just one second
let's see well maybe not that's about as
close as I can actually you know what
let me really zoom in on this book let
me get it here let me see if I
can God damn it come on come on let me
let me zoom in on this let me zoom in on
the book here and let's see oh here it
is here it is all right there it is oh
that's the book that he's reading okay
oh he's reading he's reading my com to
the children HH that little red book
with gold writing on
it
man I'm sorry I can't um Teddy Teddy
gah he set me up perfectly for that one
today so thank you thank you Teddy
Graham for for posting that picture
right over top of Nick Nick Adams post
there all right all right I got another
clip I want to show you about
this this this 14th Amendment thing and
then we're gonna get out of here for
Christmas that's right I'm Gonna Let You
Go you're gonna get out of here and
you're gonna go do the Christmas thing
how you have your
Christmas you get to go Christmas the
Christmas thing what however it is that
you do that
all
right here is here is the clip this is
Laura lomer show do you guys know who
this crazy [__] weirdo is Laura lumer
oh my God she's a lunatic all right but
she had um and last night this Dave
Williams Dave Williams is the Colorado
GOP chairman all right now you would
think you would think that the GOP
chairman would know that it was
Republicans who brought this case maybe
he does maybe he doesn't I don't know um
but it's really weird what he says in
this clip on the Laura lomer show and I
don't understand why people aren't
catching some of this stuff because
they're always yelling and screaming
like Ted Cruz is like oh man Liberals
are so mad wiener wiener wiener weener
wiener and then they're like oh Liberals
are groomers groomer groomer groomer
weener weener weener weener weener
wiener underage children it's really
weird stuff um but here is the his name
is Dave Williams uh he's the Colorado
GOP chair and he was actually in this uh
um this Twitter space last night but I
couldn't listen to the whole thing so I
didn't catch what he says uh but I found
this clip Laura lomer posted this clip
by the way this is not someone else
posted this clip of Laura lomer she
[__] post this and the crazy thing is
she ends up in my timeline on Twitter
like crazy because that [__] crazy
[__] follows me Laura lomer is a crazy
[__] [__] and she follows me on
Twitter for some reason I have no idea
why I don't know so she can keep up with
what the [__] I'm saying or what but she
follows me on Twitter um but this is her
podcast and this is Dave Williams this
is a Colorado GOP chairman listen to
what the conversation that they have and
see if you can catch who they think
Their audience is listen someone asked
me what's sort of the sentiment I'm
feeling right now about this and I I
won't say it for some of your uh viewers
that might be underage but
what did he just say that Laura lumer
has underage people listening to her
show are you [__] serious yes I said
the c-word yeah I said it she's a [__]
oh you don't like it
she's a [__] what do you want from me
you want me to lie I'm not lying when I
say that she's a [__] [__] [__] [__]
[__] [__] huge [__] what do you want
from me oh you don't want me to say the
word [__] I'm really
sorry not really I'm not that sorry but
but but they think that she has an
underage audience here but listen to it
listen go back go back to it again Watch
essentially I'd like like to to let you
know that how when Elon Musk was asked
about the censorship he was facing on X
he said you know basically go f yourself
oh that's why he doesn't want to say it
he doesn't want to say it because
there's underage kids listening to her
show all
right all right
listen
I does Laura lomer have a huge underage
audience why are these people grooming
these children then if she has a huge
underage audience huh I mean obviously
this guy thinks she has a huge underage
audience and is not even willing to say
the word [__] are you serious as if as
if underage people haven't heard the
word [__] or somehow the word [__] is
gonna oh it's GNA damage him list listen
listen listen to me listen really good
curse words don't damage
people some people get offended and
that's their right to be offended but
words especially curse
words don't damage people you can use
words and aim them at people to damage
them but the word itself the word itself
is not damaging okay it's kind of like
the word [__] it's just a sound that
comes out of your mouth it depends on
how you use
it I hope that I'm using the word [__]
in a way when I talk about Laura lomer
that will damage her yes I'm doing that
all right listen though listen to what
how they banter back and forth f
yourself that's my sentiment right now
to the corrup Deep just say it Dem just
say it you know because I I I I I say it
all the time on my show oh oh she says
it all the time on her show in front of
her underaged audience she says it all
the time just say it just say it you
know it's a bad word uh Liberals are
[__] the Demonic
ones come on man come on are we still
pretending this [__] I'll say it with
you you know you can say it honestly you
should you should say it and then it
will be broadcasted all over Colorado
you should say it live on Lumar
Unleashed sure go [__] yourself right
that's right Elon Musk oh yeah to quote
Elon Musk Elon Musk came up with the
phrase go [__] yourself get the [__] go
[__] yourself Elon mus did not come up
with that phrase you stupid [__] what
are you talking about you think Elon
Musk came up with the phrase go [__]
yourself [__] out of here with this
[__] nonsense come
on what I mean the one thing that I
caught though is that
Laura lomer has an underage audience
it's one thing I'm wondering
about I don't know maybe I'm maybe I'm
crazy all right let's go see if there's
any news oh wait wait I do I'm getting
news I'm getting I'm getting news here I
hear I have I have I have a
response it's not it's Glenn but it's
not Glenn number two it's apparently
it's
Glenn is it Glenn no this is Glen 2 here
is Glen 2 uh no no no wait is it Glen 2
or oh it's Glen 2000 is responding uh to
my here it is there it is straight from
the laboratory apparently Glenn 2000
this is Glenn this isn't Glenn 2 this is
Glenn
2000 is
responding is responding uh to my uh to
my stance on the Supreme Court's
decision of the 14th amendment in
Colorado uh deciding to keep Cornelius
scor
again
oh Glenn 2000 Glenn
2000 see I like to have fun I like that
fun people saying uh dark
Glenn
Jim wants me to leave Glenn B I can't I
can't I can't stop I can't
stop someone said last night um because
a lot of people know that I a lot of
people know that I am not um in the camp
with Glenn on this 14th Amendment
[__] I'm not in that camp can you
tell um but the thing is is
that hey justice justice matters Justice
matters well if it matter so much why
aren't you trying to forth all the
Congress people and
Senators that help commit Insurrection
like Donald Trump did why aren't you
doing that why aren't you 14 teing them
why aren't you 14 teing the January 6
defendants that are running on tickets
in congressional districts who have been
charged and imprisoned for the
Insurrection on January
6 Glenn 2000's mad at me look at him
look at him he's so pissed off Justice
matters again I you know I'm being
serious if Justice matters why aren't
they filing cases against actual January
6 defendants who went to prison and
they're not trying to take them off
ballot why why aren't they why isn't
there's this Scourge I mean that's an
easy 14th Amendment dunk you know that
right they've been convicted of this
stuff they went to prison for this stuff
it's easy it's easy to take them off the
ballot big step fan I know I got all
kinds of good points listen this is why
this is all nonsense and this is all
[__] I know you want to have it
great where you don't have the risk of
Donald Trump being on a ballot the
problem is that's not how it works it's
not how it works it's not you're gonna
find that out with this Supreme Court
decision
you're going to find that out you're
going to [__] around and you're going to
find out listen if you were so [__]
hellbent on keeping everyone who
committed Insurrection off ballots then
why haven't you tried your damnest to
keep these [__] January 6
insurrectionists who were convicted and
went to prison off
ballots
why why oh that's right because it's not
about them it ain't about the
insurrection it ain't about keeping
insurrectionist off ballots that's not
what it's about that's not what it's
about it's not what it's
about it's about
Trump all about Trump it's all about
Trump it's all about Trump John says no
standing there's plenty of standing any
Republican any Republican primary
candidate could take the standing that
they had in Colorado in these states to
take them off ballots and Glenn could
find people that would fund it Glenn
2000 because he's really pissed
off it's not about that it's not about
it's not about Insurrection it's not
about keeping insurrectionist off
ballots it's not about keeping
insurrectionist out of our government
it's not what it's about it's not what
it's about it's about Trump and they're
making they're making this all about One
[__] and they're changing the
entire [__] their entire [__]
narrative for him and that's the wrong
thing to do uh Susan Susan has been um a
a someone who's watched the show for a
long time and I I want to point this out
because she does not agree with me on
this issue she says you're [__]
around Tony you're [__] around I
think she said you're [__] around
Tony Susan I love to have you here and
and I I like that you have a different
opinion of me I like Des scent I do I
listen if if I really hated desent I
would block every single person that
didn't like my opinion on this I would
have blocked them a long time ago and
shut them up in my chat and push my
narrative but I want you to think about
it I want you to think about it I want
you to think about the ramifications
that this has on our democracy and if it
takes me like yelling and screaming and
and pissing off Glenn
2000 because I like Glenn I do I like
Glenn someone said they like Glenn in
the chat I like Glenn I think Glenn's a
smart dude I think he's a really smart
dude uh here it was a Jan said that I
like Glenn I think he's a smart dude
I've I've talked to Glenn on camera I've
talked to Glenn on camera before and I
think Glenn knows who I am Glenn follows
me on all the social media I've talked
to him uh again on a show before I've
asked him questions he's answered we we
had a back and forth I think a couple
times I've talked to Glenn and and again
it's not that I think Glenn is trying to
undermine democracy I think he's trying
to fight for democracy he's doing it the
wrong way is what I believe it's my
opinion and I'm trying to give you a
stance so that you can think about it
and I'm being authentic I'm not trying
to make something up right this is my
real feeling on this I I I'm not just
saying this on the show I say this
[__] in private meetings I tell
people out there and when I'm out and
about I tell them
this because you got to be authentic in
your commentary you can't not be
authentic that's why I think the 14th
Amendment thing isn't authentic because
if it was authentic you would be working
your ass off to try to point out that
there's January 6 insurrectionists that
were charged and went to prison for it
that are trying to get on ballots and
are getting on primary ballots in States
they're doing that they're doing
that um Adder says differing of opinions
is democracy that's right right it's
right um appan says I kindly disagree
and you're welcome to disagree because
that's what democracy is about is about
is about
descent and and and cordial
descent and you know what if I'm wrong
I'm wrong if I'm wrong I'm wrong you
guys know that if I'm wrong I'm wrong
I'm not wrong so far I now I didn't I I
will say this I did not think this
Supreme Court would rule the way they
ruled but I am not surprised the way
they ruled because basically what they
said in their decision is that we want
the Supreme Court to decide which is
what I said all along I said all along
all you're going to do is force these
cases to go to the Supreme Court and
what you're going to do is let this
Supreme Court decide this question which
is not what I
want I don't think the Supreme Court
should decide this question especially
this Supreme Court that's my problem
that I have with it I think it
undermines our
democracy for the future not right now
not right now not in this moment because
our future is so so much more important
than Trump it's so much more important
than MAA it's so much more important
than trying to help Liz Cheney and Paul
Ryan revive the Republican party that's
dead it's so much more important
our democracy is the one thing that we
have to
protect we have to protect it we have to
protect it no matter what the threats
are even if we see a threat that could
be a threat in the future we must speak
out against it we must say something we
must and that's what I appreciate about
the [__] them fam that's what I
appreciate about The Descent in the chat
because there are certain issues that
you guys feel that are so important to
your democracy that you're willing to
stand on your principles and you're
willing to defend your position and that
is the most important thing going into
the holiday
folks it's the most important thing
going into the
holiday that you descent against people
who aren't defending
democracy that you stand on your
principles that you defend your position
authentically don't make up some [__]
because it's popular online don't make
up some [__] because you don't want to
offend people [__] that that's all weak
ass [__] snowflake type stuff okay
we got to get [__] tough now it's
time we gotta fight for our [__]
democracy to save it and it's going to
be a hell of a year one hell of a
[__] year that we're going to throw
into in 2024 and what I want you to do
is I want you to engage in this
democracy whether that be coming here
every [__] week day for two full
hours Monday through Friday noon Eastern
11 Central 9 Pacific are you're out
there in real
life defending democracy defending the
positions of democracy defending its
foundation and if it takes me giving you
my opinion and even if you don't agree
with me 100% of the the time to get you
fired
up to defend your actual authentic
positions not make some [__] up because
it's popular online or you saw some
meme but deep down in your
soul you believe in equity you believe
in equality you believe that diversity
is what makes our nation unique and
strong and that liberalism is a
weakness
it's difficult it's difficult to
compromise it really is it's a thing as
humans that we do not want to do we
don't want to do it like a lot of people
in the chat Love Glenn 2000 they love
him and they love what he's saying about
the 14th
Amendment and they're not willing to
compromise on that no matter what I say
or how I point it out or how I shape it
or or you know make it
smell
that's
good no matter how bad that might be
good but compromise is
difficult but compromise and descent is
what democracy is built on and if we
defend our democracy and our
Constitution that affords us the rights
and the
freedoms that we have in this country it
is the vehicle that will deliver us the
liberty that we desire because
ultimately at the end of the day that's
what this entire experiment is really
about it's about
everyone all people having their real
true Liberty and don't forget that and
also have a merry Christmas happy
holiday will'll be back next week
Wednesday so we'll be back before the
first of the year so I get to tell you
Happy New Year then but you know what if
you don't get to watch me next week
happy [__] New Year too Merry [__]
Christmas happy [__] New Year but
that's right this is the last show we
will have until next week Wednesday next
week Wednesday we will be back here on
Facebook YouTube twitch and now
Instagram and now Instagram same time
same place I love every single one of
you Merry [__] Christmas
Surfs Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events in
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__] them
[Music]
Murphy's mebn head ass
speaking
[Music]
Jingle Bells Tony's got a cough can't
seem to shake it off it's really getting
love siing hot C by for Christmas tree
but all I hear is Tony cing can't you
see cing cing he juston
stop Tony's got a and it's
going jingle bells jingle bells mix with
coughing sounds but we still Rock the
holidays spread all around coughing
coughing jingling through the night
[Music]
Ton's got a cough but we'll still be all
right